el regreso de los talibanes afganistán
confirmó haci bulat javi y a su familia
que haber huido a ecuador hace cinco
años para rehacer su vida lejos del
conflicto fue una decisión acertada
escapar de la guerra de
el peligro que tenía nuestra familia de
repente yo les entiendo entonces
nosotros escapamos del peligro shavit se
dedica al comercio sin embargo en las
últimas semanas se ha convertido en un
intermediario para tramitar apoyo
humanitario a sus compatriotas que
quieren ir ecuador pero la posibilidad
se aleja luego que el canciller de la
república mauricio montalvo afirmó que
ecuador no podría recibir por el momento
los 5.000 afganos que había prometido
carta suplicando ayuda y copias de
pasaportes ocupan la sala de su casa la
tristeza no embarga por no poder ayudar
a todos como quisieras las mujeres las
niñas yo siento para ellos que siento
dolor aquí en mi corazón esto me motivó
para poder buscar apoyo para esta gente
ecuador es el país latinoamericano que
ha otorgado más visas a los fast canós
455 en total que en los últimos nueve
años según datos de la cancillería
ecuatoriana
de esa cifra
135 han sido entregadas a solicitantes
de refugio 102 a personas que
necesitaban protección internacional 135
de turismo 10 para visitas no mayores a
90 días
con fines diplomáticos 22 amparados por
consanguinidad 3 por actos de comercio y
36 relacionadas a estudiantes
profesionales o trabajo
[Música]
vaya a mi llamar otro afgano que llegó a
ecuador por decisión de sus padres hace
19 años está agradecido con el país que
lo acogió cuando nosotros llegamos aquí
como dimos a decirle refugio cosas y
como siempre fue un trato muy bueno muy
cordial por parte de ellos y como normal
un trámite lo que ustedes a órganos le
vamos a dar otro trato ustedes de otro
lado otro trato no por llevar como javi
ha construido un hogar único adoro y
estaría feliz de que su comunidad se
ampliar en esa nación
sospecha que no ocurrirá porque intuye
que sus compatriotas sólo usarán la
región como un puente para llegar al
destino más solicitado por los afganos
eeuu y américa